hello my name is not rato meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development on Monday November 11 2013
since our last episode of this week in
Android development aired we've launched
Android 44 or KitKat and if you haven't
you should watch the what's new in
Android videos that we've been recording
in many different languages we might
even have a recording an American if we
ever get around to it in addition to
what's new and kitkat there's a lot of
Awesome deadlights that we've recorded
there in one convenient playlist that
you should watch as well to get an idea
to get an idea of what's new and
improved in android for dot for this
week the DevOps conference is in session
in Belgium where a few people from the
Android developer relations team will be
presenting now if you're on this side of
the planet rado Meyer will be the
keynote speaker at and def con in san
francisco this wednesday that's all for
this week in Android development be sure
to check out this week's bites I'm not
rey de Meyer and I hope you two are
having a beautiful day